♪ ♪
>> Greg: BIDENS BEACH HOUSE
GETS A BARRIER WHILE THE BORDER
CRISIS GETS SCARIER.
WEEKS CAN'T STOP THE CARAVAN IN
OUR DIRECTION BUT HE GETS A
FENCE FOR HIS OWN PROTECTION.
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
IS PAYING MORE THAN $450,000 IN
TAXPAYER MONEY TO SECURE THE
FENCING AROUND JOE'S BEACH HOUSE
IN DELAWARE.
THE SAME JOE BIDEN WHO STOPPED
CONSTRUCTION OF THE WALL AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
BUT TO BE FAIR, JOE SPENDS
FILMIC FENCE IS TO KEEP HIM FROM
WANDERING INTO THE NEIGHBORS
YARD.
HE KEEPS GIVING SPEECHES FROM
BEHIND THE BIRD BATH AND JUST
ANNOYING.
SO EVEN BIDEN --
WORTH
BECAUSE THIS FENCE GOES UP, NEW
CARAVAN WITH 2,000 MIGRANTS IS
PAWING THROUGH MEXICO LIKE BRIAN
THROUGH A FIVE LAYER WEDDING
CAKE.
HE ORDERS THEM AND HE'S NOT EVEN
GOING TO A WEDDING.
THEY'VE ARTIE MADE THEIR WAY
PAST MEXICAN ARMED FORCES UNDER
HEADING THIS WAY.
IN FISCAL YEAR, 2021,
1.7 MILLION MIGRANTS ACROSS THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY.
AND THERE IS NO SOLUTION IN
SIGHT.
CERTAINLY NOT FROM KAMALA.
THEY PUT HER BACK TO WORK ON THE
NATIONAL GENDER STRATEGY.
PROBABLY BECAUSE SHE IS A DAME.
A SEXIST WOULD SAY.
THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT BIDEN, WHAT GIVES?
>> DON'T TELL ME ABOUT THE
BORDER.
I KNOW THE BORDER.
I HAVE BEEN THERE.
I WENT THERE IN 2008.
AND COME ON, IT'S LONG.
YOU CAN'T GET A FENCE ON IT.
IT'S TOO LONG.
SO I PUT A FENCE AROUND MY
PLACE.
EVERYBODY ELSE SHOULD DO THE
SAME THING.
IT'S LIKE A MASK.
MY FENCE IS TO PROTECT YOU.
AND HALF A MILLION DOLLARS,
THAT'S NOT BAD FOR A FENCE.
HALF A MILLION, THAT'S WHAT
HUNTER GETS FOR ONE OF HIS
PAINTINGS.
COME ON, THEY'RE NOT THAT'S
GOOD.
>> Greg: EMILY, IT'S SUCH AN
OBVIOUS COMPARISON TO MAKE, BUT
I CAN'T RESIST.
HE GETS ON WALL, AMERICA
DOESN'T.
HE ACCEPTS THE LOGIC OF THE
WALL.
SPEAK UP WHAT ELSE DO YOU EXPECT
FROM SOMEONE WHO SPENDS OUR
MONEY WITHOUT RESTRAINT, INCLUDG
HIS SALARY QUESTION MICAH
REMINDS ME OF WHEN I USED TO
LIVE IN SEATTLE AND I WOULD WALK
MY DOG BY A HOMELESS ENCAMPMENT
AND THE NEIGHBOR WAS BUILDING
THIS HUGE FENCE AROUND THEIR
HOUSE.
SO ON TOP OF ALL THE TAX DOLLARS
AND THEY HAD TO PAY WITH HER AND
MANY A FENCE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY WERE KEPT SAFE FROM
EVERYONE IN THE CAMP OR
WHATEVER.
SO HE IS ACKNOWLEDGING EXACTLY
-- TO THE TUNE OF ALL OF HER
MONEY.
REMEMBER THE CONTRACTS THAT WERE
RECENTLY CANCELED AND ALL THE
FUNDS GOING FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROJECTS.
>> Greg: I REMEMBER THAT LIKE
IT WAS YESTERDAY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> BASICALLY ALL OF OUR TAX
DOLLARS GOING TO BORDER
INFRASTRUCTURE, IT DOESN'T ZOOM
INCLUDE THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO
THE WALL AND NOW HE IS SPENDING
500,000 OF OUR TELEX DOLLARS ON
HIS OWN FENCE
>> Greg: KAT, CLEARLY THIS
FENCE IS A HATEFUL MESSAGE.
HE SAYS I NEED A BARRIER BETWEEN
ME AND PEOPLE, MANY LIKELY
MINORITIES.
HE COULD BE A RACIST.
>> HE SAID THAT?
>> Greg: I SAID THAT.
>> NO, I DON'T THINK EVERYONE
WHO HAS A FENCE IS RACIST, NO.
>> Greg: BUT THE WALL'S RACE
HAS PEERED >> I DON'T LIKE THE
WALL.
I NEVER ONE OF THE WALL.
I THINK WE SHOULD REMOVE WELFARE
INCENTIVE AND INSTEAD WE CAN
SAVE MONEY ON WALL AND THEN MY
HUSBAND IS MORE CONSERVATIVE
THAN I AM AND HE'S LIKE OH, WE
HAVE A WALL IN THE APARTMENTS.
AND I'M LIKE YEAH, I WOULD BE
COLD.
THEN I SAY I'M KIND OF COLD
RIGHT NOW.
AND THEN ON AND ON.
>> Greg: THAT'S AMAZING.
I FEEL LIKE I WAS REALLY THERE.
>> WE HAVE BEEN --
BUT NO, I DON'T THINK IT'S THE
PERFECT ANALOGY.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
BUT IT WAS AN EASY ONE.
>> IT WAS.
YOU ARE A BUSY MAN.
>> Greg: I DON'T HAVE TIME TO
COME UP WITH DIFFICULT
ANALOGIES.
THIS ONE MADE SENSE.
IT'S RED MEAT.
>> IT WAS.
>> I WILL GIVE YOU THAT.
THE LAST COUPLE TIMES I'VE SEEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN, ESPECIALLY IN
TOWN HALL, I KEEP FEELING LIKE I
AM IN "ROCKY 4" WATCHING HIM GET
KILLED.
PLEASE STOP.
I FEEL LIKE IF YOU CORNERED HIM
AND SAID WHAT'S UP WITH A FENCE,
HE WOULD BE LIKE WHAT?
I DON'T THINK HE KNOWS WHAT'S
GOING ON ANYMORE.
IT'S PAINFUL TO WATCH SEEING THE
PEOPLE AROUND HIM.
IT'S PROBABLY HIS WIFE PUT A
FENCE.
LIKE LITERALLY WE ARE SEEING,
BUT HE HAS SUCH A GREAT ACE UP
HIS SLEEVE.
DOESN'T MATTER IF IT IS DEMENTIA
OR WHATEVER MEDICAL AILMENT IS
HAVING.
NOT JUST GAPS ANYMORE.
BUT HE IS THIS AMAZING TRUMP
CARD THAT HE CAN PLAY AT ANY
TIME.
WANT TO GET RID OF ME?
BECAUSE THE REPUBLICANS ARE LIKE
OH, NO -- NO WERE NOT.
BECAUSE OF WHAT THE PROGRESSIVE
MONSTER BEHIND HIM IS COMING,
THE MACHINE IS COMING.
SO THAT'S WHY YOU ARE NOT SEEING
THE RIGHT TALK THAT MUCH,
SERIOUS TALK ABOUT TRYING TO GET
RID OF THEM BECAUSE WE CAN'T.
>> Greg: THE NEXT IN LINE.
CURTIS, WHAT WOULD YOU DO WITH
THE BORDER?
>> THE FENCE IS INTERESTING.
SOME OF THE AUDIENCE WEREN'T
EVEN BERTHED AT THAT TIME BUT
REMEMBER --
REMEMBER HOW HE WAS SAVAGE
BECAUSE HE SAID I NEED AN
ELECTRIFIED FENCE AROUND MY
HOUSE.
I AM THE TARGET OF TERRORISTS.
HE WAS.
I LOOK AT THE WALL AND I SAY
THAT'S HOW TERRORISTS ARE COMING
IN.
AS MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY, IF
THE VOTE IS ELECT ME ON NOVEMBEY
CONCERN.
BECAUSE THE THIRD TIME WILL BE
THE CHARM.
THEY KNOW YOU WANT NEW YORK.
1992 THEY TRIED.
AND OBVIOUSLY 9/11 THEY WERE
SUCCESSFUL.
BUT THEY WANT TO COME BACK WITH
HER IT'S AL QAEDA, ISIS, OR ANY
OF THOSE KNOCKOFF GROUPS, THEY
WANT THE BIG APPLE.
THE TERRORISTS ARE COMING
THROUGH THAT VOID THAT IS BEEN
CREATED.
SOME MAY BE OUT OF THE THOUSANDS
MARCHING UP FROM MEXICO, THERE
COULD BE TEN TERRORISTS.
HOW WOULD WE KNOW?
THERE IS NO VETTING PROCESS PEER
THERE IS NO BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WE KNOW ALREADY TERRORISTS HAVE
BEEN CAUGHT OF THE FEW THAT HAVE
BEEN IN THE CATCH BASIN.
SO THAT IS WHAT OUR BIGGEST
CONCERN WOULD HAVE TO BE.
IF YOU ARE A TERRORIST AND SOME
HOBBLE IN SOUTH YEMEN, I WILL
GET YOU, MY LITTLE PRETTY.
THIS WILL BE THE BIG TIME.
WAS THE BEST WAY TO GET INTO THE
COUNTRY?
RIGHT ACROSS THE BORDER FROM
MEXICO INTO AMERICA.
>> Greg: I WOULD BE A TERRIBLE
TERRORISTS.
I AM SO LAZY.
>> YOU WOULD GET TOO NERVOUS.
>> Greg: I WOULD GET TO
NEVERS.
>> YOU TALK.
>> Greg: I WOULD GET UPSET.
>> THERE WOULD BE A SCATHING
EMAIL RIGHT BEFORE THE ATTACK.
>> Greg: I GET THE MIC SEND
ONE SCATHING EMAIL TO YOU AND
YOU WANT --
>> ONLY ONE YOU LITTLE
TERRORISTS.